this that change will happen this
weekend eight news now reporter joe
moeller joining us live from a tavern
down in the southwest valley joe and
bars will have though to wait until
sunday night correct
yeah that's right they'll have to wait
pretty late on sunday 11 59
p.m to be exact task force officials say
they are pleased with the progress
in southern nevada and as you can
imagine bar owners and employees are now
pleased too
because their tips have been suffering
people have not been coming in as much
taylor lilly owns scoundrel's pub in
north las vegas he shut down the inside
bar in july but sunday night that will
change
employees are very excited everybody's
excited to get back to work
customers are excited i've been getting
text messages and facebook messages
the nevada kova 19 mitigation and
management task force voted to allow
bars taverns wineries and distilleries
to reopen sunday at 11 59 p.m
they must follow social distancing
guidelines i think we could go all the
way back
to the beginning and and see where
clark county has come from task force
officials are happy with the decreasing
trending cases in clark county
in addition to improvement to case
investigations southern nevada health
district now has no backlog in their
case investigation that was not the case
three weeks ago and so i want to
acknowledge them for their efforts
they're now able to
get to cases for the most part within 24
hours and do that case investigation
health officials say as businesses
remain closed mental health related
problems are a growing concern
they also explain social distancing
compliance checks with businesses are
showing positive results
i think it's great news i think we need
to open our state lilly says
safety will be a number one priority
we're still going to have glass
partitions
and we're still going to do all the
safety precautions that we've
put in place
again bars and bar tops cannot open
until 11 59
p.m on sunday night they must operate at
50 percent capacity
and dance areas and billiards areas with
inside those bars
must remain closed reporting live in the
southwest valley joe mohler 8 news now